so squid game was a big deal right
biggest show in the world this year and
season two is coming so you know they
have some twist reveals in store so
consider this illnob player001 is the
father of guyon player four five six one
is the first player one is the last so
there's already a connection there but
why in the world would i say they'd be
family well in episode three ilnam says
that his son was allergic to milk just
like yon ilnam grew up in the game four
neighborhood just like gion even down to
a very specific alleyway on the 24th
ilnam says that his son's birthday is
coming up and gion when he enters his
birthday in the atm in episode 1 types
in 4 26. oh and if you pay enough
attention you'll also see that they both
share a family name yeah i was just as
shocked as you are so does this mean
that these gangbu are better described
as father and son and now that gyan is
rich he's gonna rise to take over the
family business in the newly announced
season two well that my friends is what
we're gonna prove or disprove today
somebody call maury you are the father
hello internet welcome to film theory
the show that looks at a popular show
and thinks
all joking but also not joking aside
squid game took not just the internet
but the whole world by storm and
everyone has been milking this cow dry
even mainstream news outlets have been
clamoring to find more content and fast
so they decided to scrape the bottom of
the barrel and started to go where no
mainstream news outlet has gone before
they started talking about theories but
not their own theories of course not
they started write articles that just
rehashed other people's theories and of
them all there was one theorist that
rose above the rest one that mainstream
media could not ignore a theorist whose
theories were recognized and hailed as
brilliant the internet over and that
theorist was on tick-tock
man tick tocker ruth bellpen had a post
go viral when she proposed that our hero
456 gion and the twist villain number
zero zero one ilnom were actually
related more specifically that illnom is
guillan's father that the old man is
actually his father that's right squid
game just went and pulled the star wars
on us and then forgot to put in the big
reveal i gotta admit reading the
headline i thought this one was pretty
dumb sure you can claim anything you
want alfred is bruce wayne's father
wolverine is secretly deadpool palpatine
is rey's grandfather now but actually
having evidence to back it up is
something else entirely trust me i've
made plenty of big leaps over the last
10 years but then i started to dig a bit
deeper and yeah the evidence is
certainly compelling at least when you
look at that evidence on the surface
i've seen popular tick-tock theories
before that look good on the surface but
ultimately crumble under the actual
research so today as the internet
self-proclaimed theory expert we're
putting this one to the test is it
possible that illnom is guillan's secret
father and that they're saving the
reveal for season two ladies and
gentlemen it's morty time leave your
theories in the comments below
i'll pick my favorites in the next
episode of morty now here's the thing
throughout the show we don't learn
anything about guillain's father his
mother is a big part of the story and
her medical issues are one of the key
reasons he enters the squid game in the
first place but as for his father
there's no pictures of him around the
house there's no talk of him nothing
which ultimately leaves the door open
for someone to appear and fill that role
as such there's definitely the
possibility that illnom is the man for
the job so let's start by breaking down
what ruth belpin called out in her tock
first we have this scene hey is there
any chocolate milk i can't drink the
normal kind my goodness
as a kid i'm willing to bet you got
spanked a lot how did you know
my son did too he was just like you
friend she believes that this might be
hinting at a connection between the two
characters one got spanked for not
liking milk the other had a son that got
spanked for the exact same thing maybe
it's implied that that's why the
spanking occurred but it's not sure
regardless i gotta say ethics is
spanking aside punishing a kid for being
lactose intolerant are you sure about
that now one comment alone does not a
theory make but as ruth bell pin points
out this isn't the first time that geon
and ilnam's pasts overlap in episode six
we have the marble game and as soon as
they both enter we get this line when i
was a kid i lived in a neighborhood just
like this so did i okay but that's just
a coincidence right i mean that's a
comment about ilnom's childhood not his
adult life as a parent so what's the
real connection here well later in the
same episode illna also says this yes
this is it my wife and i have this one
here i raised my son
right in here he found the exact house
that he and his family lived in in a
neighborhood that gion seems to also
recognize and not only recognize but
actively call out and you know something
our alleyway looked very similar
okay it's one thing for both men to grow
up in a lower income neighborhood it
would make sense that they would
recognize the general vibe but it's
another thing to outright call out a
specific alley way now that is
suspicious in fact it was so suspicious
that i dug around a bit more and noticed
that the gates outside of the houses and
brick walls of the marbles arena looked
nearly identical to the ones around
geon's home that we see in episode 1.
the final piece of evidence she calls
out is when the old man asks for the
date hold on
what's today's date
my son has his birthday soon
what day is it
the 24th well eagle-eyed viewers will
remember that in episode 1 geon punches
the date of his birthday as a pin number
in the atm and we learn that his
birthday falls on the 26th if ilnam's
son's birthday is close to the 24th i'd
say the 26th is pretty darn close and
lastly there's one additional piece of
evidence that i've seen circling reddit
not exactly sure who is the first to say
it i saw it posted by bright light
shonjin but they claim it was originated
on a korean website so hard to say for
sure anyway it's about the importance of
names in the series specifically the
names of ill-nom and geon's mother when
gyan steals his mother's credit card at
the start of episode 1 we actually see
the face of it for a few seconds on the
card we can see her name clearly printed
oh malsun now this is hugely important
because ilnam's family name also is oh
oh ill nom we see it in the imdb credits
for the character as well as hear it in
the final episode
is that even your real name huh
it is
yes that's real
which means that there's absolutely a
family connection there plus their names
actually mean something from what i've
read ilnam means first boy or first man
while malsoon means last person or last
girl with something that obvious surely
that's hinting at the connection between
these two characters geon's father is
the first man and his mother is the last
girl it's like poetry overall some
interesting details seem to line up and
all of this is without even mentioning
the fact that just the choice to include
these little details feels intentional
it feels like a series of easter eggs
that'll pay off at some point but before
we start digging into these specific
points i also wanted to throw some
observations into the ring all the
evidence up to this point has been
circumstantial if you really want to
prove parentage and if you've watched
any of my channels over the years you
know that you gotta look at genetics
looking at these two characters side by
side there's a number of similarities
that would point to them being related
they both have brown eyes easy they both
have brown black hair provided we're
talking about illness hair before it
turned gray and guillains before it um
went the way of 2016 era markiplier even
their hairline is similar something
which is also passed down from parents
to you you see there are two kinds of
hairlines from a genetic perspective a
straight hairline where the hair just
goes straight across the top of your
head or a widow's peak hairline where
the hairline forms a kind of m shape the
widow's peak is actually the dominant
gene so the fact that both of these
characters share a straight hairline or
what's left of it anyways gives further
credence to the theory that they're both
related their earlobes are also both
detached another genetically determined
trait in fact all across their faces
they share similarities similar brows
similar chin similar crow's feet all
indicators of a genetic family
relationship all of which are shared by
the two characters genetics also helps
determine whether someone is right or
left-handed and if we look carefully we
see both characters using their right
hands to sign their lives away when
signing up for the games but genetics
doesn't just affect physical features it
can also affect a person's personality
we know that gion is a neglectful father
one that's now divorced and unable to
fully commit to his daughter even after
he just won millions of dollars and has
the chance to get on a plane to spend
time with her father of the year right
there folks though we don't know much
about illna we do know that he's alone
on his deathbed in the final episode
which could imply that he too was
estranged from his family this would
also explain why his memories of his son
are all from when they were just a child
because there came a point when illnom
just wasn't around anymore now what i'm
about to say might come as a surprise
and i gotta admit i was taken aback by
this too when i found it in my research
but to not share it seems like it would
be irresponsible you see divorce seems
to at least be in part tied to genetics
yeah when i found this in my research i
was just as shocked as you are you see
for years it was assumed that if parents
were divorced then the children were
also more likely to get divorced thanks
to the normalization of divorce and
established family environment but there
was a study by vcu and lund university
in sweden that actually found that
genetics play a bigger part than you'd
expect sure genetics don't physically
give you a desire to divorce but what
genetics can affect are your base
emotions and your brain chemistry
according to the study people can
inherit high levels of negative emotions
this in turn caused people to see their
partners as more controlling or
generally view them in a more negative
light which in turn would lead to a
higher chance of divorce this isn't the
only psychological trait that can be
passed down through genetics either
there was a study carried out by the
university of missouri and the
queensland institute of medical research
on
2889 pairs of twins to see whether
genetics played a role in their gambling
habits it turned out that an identical
twin was more likely to have gambling
habits if the other twin was also a
gambler this boiled down to them
estimating that if someone had three or
more pathological gambling symptoms
there was a 58 chance that it was
inherited by their parents gion is a
compulsive gambler in the show and we
can reasonably conclude that illnom is
as well he created the games he
entertains the vips he even gambles with
geon on his deathbed is this conclusive
evidence no but is it evidence that we
can add to the pile absolutely so that's
it theory confirmed right we can all
pack it up and call it a day said no one
ever see all this evidence is pretty
darn convincing until you do what i do
and over analyze the over analysis
that's when things start to fall apart
let's start with the name connection
which to me is one of the biggest things
holding this thing together well yes
it's a cool little easter egg let's stop
and look at it from a cultural
standpoint in the west when people get
married typically the wife takes the
husband's last name it's not always the
case but it's very common in south korea
though the family name the name that you
say first is handed down to your
children but not to your wife so the
fact that both ilnam and malsun share a
family name doesn't imply a husband and
wife relationship and this also brings
up another crucial point o is just an
incredibly common family name in south
korea according to the 2015 census there
were over 700 000 people all using the
family name oh so when you gather up 456
of them you're inevitably gonna have
some people with the same family name it
doesn't mean that they're all related in
fact that's exactly what we see happen
in the show not only is zero zero one an
o but so is contestant 118 118
1.02 billion speaking of commonalities
all those genetic clues that i pointed
out earlier also super common look at
any group shots from the show how many
of these people all have brown eyes and
brown black hair they are the dominant
traits after all same thing with
right-handedness of course being
right-handed is the most common trait
worldwide but it's even more common in
south korea than it is elsewhere where
only four percent of koreans use their
left hand for eating and one percent for
writing if you're right-handed you just
make up the overwhelming majority of the
country and are exactly the same as the
other 95 so trying to use those genetic
traits to prove a connection is
ultimately fruitless as none of our
characters have especially interesting
features even the straight hairline
which i did call out as a recessive gene
is actually more common in south korea
than the dominant widow's peak gene so
across the board the one genetic trait
that made the connection special isn't
all that special when you take it from a
cultural standpoint of south korea as
for those gambling and divorce genes
pretty hard to argue that the science
exists over there but there are plenty
of other studies that prove other
factors play a part in whether people
get divorced or start gambling obviously
in fact a big reason both of those
things can start to happen is one of the
central themes of the show poverty
everyone in the squid game is down on
their luck they're in huge debt they're
unable to provide for themselves or
their family and so it makes them all
desperate enough to partake but it's
those same reasons that would make geon
susceptible to a gambling addiction and
make him far more likely to get a
divorce we know that gion was laid off
after 10 years of work now he works as a
chauffeur but clearly doesn't earn much
the gambling research exchange ontario
states that there is a connection
between gambling problems and
significant job loss with gambling
essentially becoming a coping strategy
the dopamine hit they get from winning
is a massive boost for those who are
struggling to get by see also geon's
reaction at the claw game if you're
living below the poverty line it's also
more likely to cause tensions between
parents the census bureau has stated
that quote poor two-parent families were
about twice as likely to break up as
we're two parent families not in poverty
so the fact that gion lost his job and
was struggling to find a new one that
paid enough would most likely lead to
him having more fights with his wife and
last but certainly not least the
birthday thing this is just a case of
everyone not doing their research sure
illnom says that the 24th is close to
his son's birthday and guillain's
birthday is on the 26th but look at the
month we learned via the pin code that
gion's birthday is 0-4-2-6 the 26th of
april but the series is taking place in
june we know this because of a few
seconds later when he types in this what
was it a birthday
my kids is today 0608 his daughter's
birthday june 8th today the timeline
just doesn't work out june 24th is
nowhere near geon's birthday of april
26th period and to make matters worse
the show isn't even consistent with
gion's birthday in the final episode of
the show guyon says that his birthday is
actually october 31st if you wish to
play please state your name and date of
birth
sanki you
october 31 1974 what now something is
just completely wrong not only is that
just a huge mistake for continuity but
if this was meant to be some sort of
clue alluding to a connection between a
father and a son yeah you'd think they
would have taken the time to ensure that
they had gotten it right but all of this
hard counter evidence aside the fact of
the matter is that a twist like this
just doesn't make sense we hear illness
talk about his wife and kids on a few
occasions how he'd come downstairs and
watch his wife make breakfast or how
he'd watch his son playing outside with
his friends children start to form
long-term memories from the age of 1. if
his son was old enough to play outside
unsupervised he's clearly older and the
older he gets the more memories that his
brain is going to remember so if ilnam
was the father how does gyan not
remember his father's face he also
doesn't respond when the old man says
this is the one and walks into what was
supposedly a model of his old house if
gian was indeed his son and was old
enough to play outside in the courtyard
then surely he too would remember that
childhood home and it would be a moment
that the show would call out to me this
theory is a cool idea and i like the
evidence a lot but i think we can safely
say that it's just not true it is
debunked i think squid game is
incredibly clever and has found a really
interesting way to cover a sociological
issue but i don't think it's setting up
a darth vader-esque moment at least not
in this way by giving ill-nom lines
about his wife his kids he becomes
relatable to us it humanizes him it
throws us off the scent that he was
actually the big bad the entire time the
fact it's normally in relation to gyan
is also a way of strengthening their
bond as characters making gian's
betrayal of this forgetful old man and
his eventual fake out death even more
heartbreaking it forces us to
subconsciously compare the two of them
creating this natural way to make us
realize how similar they are but
ultimately how they became different
people illna used his fortune to create
the squid games but once gyan won he
used it to help people showing us the
one trait that separates him a trust and
care for humanity this line of thinking
is what i believe we're gonna see in
season two seeing whether gion is able
to hold on to his morals throughout
season one he was shown to be very
similar to ill-nom and now he's even
more so thanks to the money that he's
won so gion in season two is gonna face
a choice he's gonna be like luke
skywalker and have to decide whether he
keeps his morals and trust for humanity
or do like the front man did and join
the dark side and host the squid games
and i'm not even guessing about this the
creator of the show has literally come
out and said that this is likely what's
gonna happen which doesn't hit nearly as
hard if we haven't seen a connection and
similarity between these two characters
especially that moment when illnom gives
gion his zero zero one jacket showing a
symbolic passing of the torch to the
next generation question is will gion
accept that offer and the other question
is can season two possibly rise to the
heights of season one i guess we'll just
have to wait and see in the meantime
remember it's all just a theory a film
theory and
cuts hey do you know where in the world
you could possibly get away with a legal
version of the squid game we found it
and it might actually have lore
implications that video is on screen
right now so if you're interested click
it and if you're interested in debunking
the bad tick tock theories that have
been circulating around these days make
sure you subscribe to the channel
welcome to the loyal theorists